[Music]
where am i
oh no did i break into mariah carey's
penthouse and fall asleep again
oh my god are you a hot home invader
please don't kill me babe it's it's me
it's matt
your husband
excuse me
uh i think there has been a
misunderstanding you're not my husband
because i am not
oh my god this ring is huge yeah you
said if i didn't get you a big enough
ring i could get used to sing my own d
for the rest of my l that does sound
like me yes it does
morning big what hungry
yes always
last night i wished i had never gotten
together with danny and this morning my
wish came true it's like 13 going on 30
except i'm still the same age 26.
is that gramercy park i live on gramercy
park that's john stewart eating a hot
dog and we are married and he's not
wearing a yarmulke then how are we so
rich
and what's with this guy smoking hot
lives in a soap opera set and he wanted
to marry my fat ass what am i
blackmailing him okay detective mindy
just need to focus be cool and ask him
normal questions
hey honey can i see your birth
certificate what never mind
do you know what i thought would be kind
of a fun game you and i playing truth or
dare okay right i'll pick
dare goddammit
excuse me
damn it
who got this stupid box here
[Music]
which is when i tripped and fell on your
stupid box of
fish oils yeah i opened it
so uh i hope you're a good lawyer
because i plan on suing okay i have a
couple thoughts nice to meet you by the
way i'm cliff
now i could sue you for tampering with
my mail because that's a federal offense
since when it's like 18 20. uh i do that
all the time well you shouldn't if
somebody gets some interesting looking
mail you don't open it to see what's in
it no i don't
neither do i
but i am so curious who is it that you
think that you could sue uh you this law
firm the makers of fat steps weight loss
sneakers their spokesperson brook burke
her husband david charvay
let me just stop you right there
in slip and fall claims a plaintiff you
has to prove gross negligence on the
part of the defendant me now i can only
assume you weren't looking where you
were going because you clearly weren't
looking in the mirror when you got
dressed this morning uh how dare you i'm
adorable i look like keira knightley
running errands
guys love this look not that i'm
interested in guys right now cause i'm
going through a breakup well wait a
minute you're single i find that
impossible
now you're also wearing fat steps in the
rain outside of a controlled exercise
environment so i think the judge hears
that finds the plaintiff to be negligent
and clearly insane case closed have a
wonderful day everyone
you think you're so cool with all your
legal talk pacing around and your
expensive pants i can do that too guess
what i've seen legally blonde nine times
i saw it on broadway i read the
novelization i have the app
i meant to do that
so
have a nice life loser
okay you have a online shopping problem
well why don't you use a backpack
instead of a plastic bag my birthday's
coming up hold the door
oh it's you
no you don't get to owe it to me i owe
it to you whatever i'm a rape sunshine
yeah well you definitely look better
than you did yesterday
thank you i bathed
that's important
[Music]
after you
morgan it works every time
hey yo who's the hottie with the body in
the middle of the sidewalk oh my god wow
what's up
what's up i haven't walked in weeks my
pedometer thinks i'm dead oh yeah i
threw my pedometer out because it would
not acknowledge masturbation as exercise
so i don't know why my friends ever
hated you yeah i'm kidding i appreciate
the effort you put in with them that was
huge yeah of course and i don't know
what you did but the guys love you now
except for market but marcus hates
everything i mean he doesn't like matt
damon oh i am so over matt damon stop
coasting on your good looks and charm
and talent
can i try your hoverboard yeah oh for
sure really yeah all right super easy
basically just step on uh i think it'll
be fine
yeah
oh
whoa doing ah
ah
really hurts yeah really sorry i've
actually never seen anyone fall off one
of those before and i follow an
instagram that's mostly dogs riding them
well the truth is i haven't balanced
ever since i lost a swab in this year
sure yeah that'll do it yeah hey whoa
so you're serious okay yeah sorry i got
you
you're okay yeah my hero
i kind of miss being your hero saving
you from falling off things constantly
you're really good at it yeah what else
am i good at i'm good at kissing too
that's your line
that's pretty good
oh my god what what is that
pizza rat from last year it's like the
hottest viral video online that's on
your skin permanently had to get a tap
okay
[Music]
vote for pedro some napoleon dynamite i
mean if they make a nappy dino sequel
it's gonna be off the chain
okay i guess it's your body your choice
hey tonight
it's our body
[Music]
oh my god is that
a minion dressed as shrek
you know it
i'm so glad we're giving us another shot
[Music]
oh my god tom oh tom i'm so sorry i'm so
oh my god
let me help you please no it's okay i
know him we used to date
we're fine don't leave me alone with
this lady don't be theatrical am i
bleeding
um i'm bleeding i'm so sorry please tell
me here we go i didn't i taste pennies
this looks good this is you're gonna
look better than when you came in hey
you wanted like um frankenstein stitches
cause of halloween right
really it's not bad at all i'd really
want to hurt you i would have sent all
your contacts that video of you spitting
out that bite of hot pizza
hey you know what
i still owe you a wedding gift is there
anything on the registry that you still
need go back in time and don't ruin my
wedding tom i'm sorry okay i'm really
sorry back then i was like a little
messed up and i think i was kind of
drunk at the wedding too a little bit
you're really drunk away um i was hurt
then but i'm not now i'm dating a blonde
guy and i just i wish the best for both
you and you know i don't even know her
name
all right
i know i heard you too and and uh
i'm sorry
i was recording this conversation in
case you threatened me but now i'm gonna
stop
just oh me about blondie who who's this
guy his name is josh and he is an
attorney for nba players he is
definitely confident very confident
almost too confident like he can be
sometimes a little obnoxious i think but
he's very funny uh not funny in a way
that you like want to laugh all the time
but you're kind of like ah offends me so
he's a jerk no he's not a jerk i like
him he's just i wouldn't necessarily
like curl up with him and watch breaking
bad don't say anything by bringing but i
haven't seen season five yet you are so
weird about it right now don't say it
don't spoil it
that's what you can do
you say one word it ruins the whole
thing i stopped talking about you done
you're done we're not talking about it
okay um try this
okay oh oh oh oh oh lucy you're cold
mm-hmm she had this horrible cold last
week i'm good with it you might get
something
i don't get sick at all you don't
have a night for me no news
i'm not hungry
feed off my fork please
isn't that good
[Music]
you're right buddy it was just a little
piece of cut i'm so sorry bones in it
that's why hey jamie
they're doctors
are you sure
you know this has it has bones i'm like
i know please let me hide like you okay
i'm not gonna let you die in this weird
restaurant jamie should we get dessert
i think he's choking no he's okay
jamie stop
jamie oh boy jamie please stop doing
that
hey guys don't worry about it she's a
doctor she's got it
[Music]
hey i really appreciate this thank you
so much a nice payment one tonic water
thanks i will be right back
oh brother
hey
hey danny all these waters look the same
i i just don't
[Music]
you